deep fake video is [__] scary trust
and verification on the Internet is
about to become one of the biggest
conversations in the history of mankind
I do think we're going to go through a
decade or two here of really challenging
times where we might not even believe
video Forget a verification badge
watching a video you'll have to be like
is this real or not now I have optimism
that humans figure things out but I
think with you know blockchain
technology and Providence and and smart
contracts some of that whole blockchain
thing forget about the currency in nfts
the actual affirmation of it being true
I think there's some really cool
Technologies grooming in the face of
other technologies that are going to
create interesting times over the next
two three four decades